all right I think I am live cool all
right all right I think I am live floors
in go wait okay
chat I think war is in okay chat how's
everybody doing all right if you're
watching me
welcome to Borderlands 3 here the
unusual thing for us normally we're
tuned to live events where they let us
scream the game which usually don't get
to do but it's a pretty exciting
opportunity we're gonna play the game
here I played through this demo
yesterday I'm gonna get a chance to you
there we go
alright sorry about that I think I was
doubling up anyway um yeah we're gonna
be going through this demo here we're on
Promethea which is the probably second
planet you're gonna get to visit and I'm
playing as Zane here there's abilities
I'd skip this I know this works all
right so I got a assault rifle here
shotgun SMG I haven't used him yet I
used Amara yesterday so but Jordan he's
next to me I don't know if you can hear
him but he is he played Zane so he was
telling me about him I'm going to pick
two visibility's does that say something
is he can have two at the same time you
can like replace a grenade with a second
ability so I'm gonna pick the
destruct and then I'm going to pick the
sentinel all right
audios good cool I can shoot the chat by
the way so if you guys have any
questions please hit me up
I think Jordans also gonna be looking at
the chat as well so he can answer
anything unfortunately we couldn't play
co-op cuz you know still in a really
build and there's bugs and I think they
just don't want to risk it
let's see here crease weapon womp speed
kill speed ah gun damage yeah that's a
good one
ah did you struck action duration those
don't seem really useful I think I'm
gonna put points into those kills enemy
gun damage health regeneration okay I'll
try and avoid talking during
conversations by the way it wants to be
guns with legs do I have a gun in the
lake floor ready check it out what's the
alternate on this grenade launcher
alright it's pretty cool I got so I got
the shotgun it's the hyperion one oh
this is so much better than the shotgun
I had as of my yesterday
I
okay ah here we go TDR maybe this is the
gun with legs
it is indeed there you go
you know when I first saw that in the
trailer I was like I don't know about
that but having played it it's pretty
cool yo my army of robots
people like guns legs man comes like
they're awesome and again yeah I know
but I find better loot that was the
thing with the last last time I played
yesterday there were definitely cool
weapons to try out but very rarely did I
find a gun that was better than the guns
I started with
I just realized I really I'm gonna use
my abilities now that'll work
clown
Schlag me you've got some good timing
these bandits somehow got their hands on
some wicked malabon guns
[Music]
greased with Mal Awan not from around
here are you
now all these maniacs show up all over
the city screaming about some vault
that's the lips or shy Pez trying to
beat them to the vodka cells with the
coat well I got those slagging clue
about Punk's but Reese would know come
on I gotta tell them about our new
bandit problem anyway I'll introduce you
I uh crime you're asking about the
location size of the planet so check the
map here it's fairly big this this is
kind of just the first section here it's
a pretty vehicle heavy and then there's
a second section that's in the city it's
also vehicle heavy it's hard to say as
far as compared to the other borderlands
games but there are more there's a more
of an emphasis on like verticality in
multiple levels like the new mantle that
they've added to this game like lets you
kind of get to more places so it feels
pretty substantial I'm curious to see
how big each planets gonna end up being
in the final game place is compromised
anyway let me know when you're ready
grab some wheels we need to drive
through the spillways and there's always
trouble
hold on I have some better good well
it's like better damage but it's got a
higher score cuz it's like a rare weapon
I don't worry too much about it cuz I
can't even ease except to abilities
right now umm highly-effective sorry if
you guys don't want me to compare
weapons that much I can not bother with
that if you prefer I just keep playing
we'll move on for now I will grab the
side quest I don't know if I'll do it
but it's it's pretty it's pretty good
alright side mission for claptrap
someone's asking about vehicles are in
first person I do not believe so but
there is more customization than the
vehicles this time around they're like
different bodies you can get that's like
the base of the weapon and then you can
like customize skin for it try this
torque one here you can even go like in
depth with the colors if you really want
to different weapons and stuff so it's
pretty limited right now but it looks
like you can heavily customize that
stuff which is pretty cool
most of the Atlas force is around okay
so that's the main story I'm gonna go
this way because I'm gonna start the
side glass
[Music]
the vehicle controls are still very
physics II this came it feels a little
better than the other ones but uh I
don't know I've never loved the way
vehicles feel in Porter lands something
about a lost staff seriously I put that
request up like seven years ago
back when I had a respectable
establishment not this crap pile you see
now but I am glad you're here
see I'm trying to help out all the poor
bastards affected by this war but yo
straight up we are running short on med
supplies we need heck surprising scag
oil below to next and hemo packs tracks
them down for me will you my practice is
in combat trauma but my residency was in
rhyme word oh snap I forgot to give you
a mixtape yeah you know I get it you
can't straighten down your flow I'll let
you with it later
his ain't supposed to be Irish he just
he just said he just said boyo so I
think that's what they're going for
I wonder how uh actual Irish people
every time I talk to someone who's
actually Irish they're all they hate the
way most Irish accents sound and things
I talked about like Danny O'Dwyer batty
he's always like uh-uh so I wonder who
he feels about this one thing I really
like that you kind of saw there is how
the characters actually like respond and
like talk that's something they took
from the pre-sequel
that a lot of people wanted I'm really
into that I think you know these are
characters and I never liked that they
were silent
but left to keep the safe and disrupt
supply
maaan blow up there we go Oh machine
guns not that powerful
all right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bloody fantastic all right this is for
that side quest I'm gonna go back and
actually I ran past another one
let's see
we got any good questions in the chat
here yeah it looks nice I mean it's it
still looks like Borderlands a lot I
feel like the the lines are actually
thicker okay but it looks good I'm just
trying to feed my family you understand
right please don't shoot there's been
enough bloodshed around here just give
me the cash and we can make a deal you
don't know what it's like down here
people don't eat for days it's a
nightmare
okay so when I did this the first time I
didn't have enough cash to give him so
he intimidated him this time I'm gonna
give him the cash because I'm curious
what he does look you Wow thank you so
much you have no idea how much this
means to me and my family
alright so dialogue change there really
wasn't much of a difference so I'd
probably recommend you just intimidate
him to keep your money uh let's see
people are asking about graphics
settings on ultra uh I haven't looked at
the graphics settings but this is on a
PC I assume it's running at max settings
it runs pretty smooth there a couple
spots for the the framerate is pitching
up but it's an early build that's to be
expected you know all that stuff is
gonna be ironed out as I go on so that's
not really something I'm too worried
about
we're gonna grab this last thing
got it
the three seek awful skin I like that
it's good customization I do not believe
that's in this game to show off like I
couldn't find a new you station or
anything like that in the world but keep
an eye out but I don't think that's in
this demo to show off you know it's all
Harry let's get my clone out
well swapping thing with that's really
cool I'm curious I need to mess with
that more and find out like what
situation that'll be appropriate in
probably boss fights that makes the most
sense shield it enemies to get behind
them maybe that's actually a pretty good
strategy can kind of fill that role if
you're playing single player and you
don't have Sona like tight people around
follow me Oh life changes mm-hmm well uh
bond is better I didn't really mess with
this so much I mean some of the stuff
they mentioned the presentation is
really nice the fact that you can go to
a vending machine and just hit a button
to grab stuff a lot of it was like the
things they showed off like hey the
ability to find your like lost loot like
that's really cool I've had situations
where like a legendary gear actually
like fell off a cliff after I killed an
enemy and that sucked
so I'm I'm into that that's like a nice
quality of life change
[Music]
cool
uh yeah I I would say the menu I I do I
need to mess with it more but I do like
the way the menu looks it's menus and
borderlines have always been not the
best but totally serviceable this seems
a little bit cleaner one thing I like
here I'll show you it's so when you go
to the menu and you pick up like okay I
want to replace my shield it
automatically sorts it to all just your
shields rather than everything you can
still like switch your types and stuff
like that around but it knows like hey
you're not gonna put a gun here so
that's stuff like that is nice I I just
think this menu feels a little bit
cleaner it's a way easier to like
compare guns than it was before I think
it's just a lot better menu
[Music]
nope
it's something
[Music]
like it's still a little short on
hemoglobin hemoglobin disrobing is the
title track on my mixtape by the way did
you want water no still no okay screw it
I'll donate some of my own grab this
empty emo pack and give me an assist all
right
very slow yep that's right sit down come
on
I believe you very very careful all the
weight on the dialog there okay thanks
but at least maybe there's a fun they
give me some street cred sweet Atlas
robot hops hey don't worry about me I'll
survive
it's all my patience thanks to you now
Schuler is finally ready to step up and
heal the hurt oh by the way that
hardened guy stopped by he wanted you to
have this his way of saying thanks I
guess on that mixtape by the way still
no all right cool that's one of the side
missions there let's see there is I saw
one question so I was asking about if
all weapons are alternate fire modes so
no so for example this shotgun here this
Hyperion shotgun does not have an
alternate fire mode but that's because
it's got this like shield thing instead
but I've also run to like just straight
up like it's a normal gun like it's just
a normal shotgun it doesn't do anything
weird or have an alternate fire mode
it's just like a normal as Borderlands
gun and that is kind of weird because
the alternate fire modes are so cool and
they do like so many different things
like my assault rifle is great because
it's like okay it has you know normal
assault rifle but I can switch it to a
grenade launcher I found another one
that was like a shotgun instead you can
switch to that's cool
some of them it's like the the ammo type
doesn't change but what does change is
like the elemental so it's like you can
either do you know corrosive or you
could do shock so that I feel like
that's gonna make elemental stuff more
useful where I have a gun that I can
kind of like rapidly switch between the
two and I'll probably pay more attention
elemental stuff that I did
but yeah I really like the rate of the
alternate fire modes I feel like that's
a pretty significant change passwords
open the bloody door before I shove a
coffee grinder up your ass report how's
it looking a lot more patrols than usual
sir something's off we move the sibs
into the tunnels for safety bollocks
stay sharp
[Music]
I haven't the manpower to take it back
bastards packing I'm telling to like
grab weapons that aren't even that good
just because I want to like see if they
do anything interesting there we go see
these civilians malla Wan doesn't care
if they're caught in the crossfire
they're here to take over Atlas and sell
Reese's new weapons as their own so then
this war is just a merger oh yeah
definitely you could definitely like
combine alternate firing modes together
you kinda have to find like the right
setup but you would absolutely be able
to do that a side mission over there I'm
not gonna do that one maybe I'll come
back to it later but I I want to get
through to the other parts of the demo
that are more interesting you ready to
move out the base isn't far but
ah
hoping they have DLC characters yeah
they probably will
give him one
whoa never come down here if they think
we're easy targets now that they've got
bandit back up Annie way foods Jen I
really like Lorelei that's the character
I'm with right now I she's a new
character she's really cool I like her a
lot come on get ready for a fight all
right Oh where's Tiny Tina she's not in
here they haven't shown her off yet I
think they're there they're saving her
for later I'm curious to see like how
they handle her because it's supposed to
be like five years later I think so she
will be 18 at this point so she'll be a
pretty I imagine in some ways she'll be
a pretty substantially different
character like a refill hell if I could
just refill it for like money right
there that's like super easy to do I
really like that a lot boom jumpin
tracker salsa on my crap
[Music]
hold on switch this yeah let's do that
there we go I'll try this sniper out
haven't really messed with it
it's a little choppy
[Music]
Oh she'll booster
reinforcements
Oh
[Music]
some of you there you run around
yeah it's pretty cool
me that she'll be playing on controller
by the way this is on PC but they wanted
us to play the Xbox controllers I'm
guessing the PC controls aren't
optimized yet I definitely prefer I'm
used to playing Borderlands on PC let's
like my platform of choice apologize if
I'm not as accurate with like snipers or
anything like that as usual there we go
really open we can see Reece well don't
worry I have a treat for you
in just a moment once we kill these guys
dang I need more ammo
got it here we go
Oh Rach Oh
thankfully there's a ammo vending
machine
a pad
dang I'm like no mo that's gay he's dead
though are you doing there we go good
lord
[Music]
before I do that I'm gonna quickly get
in for a mo good visibility's so I
basically want to quickly show it off I
can summon a clone of myself here and
he'll shoot things and and do stuff like
that he won't really move much but he
earth at all I don't know does he move
yeah right at the beginning he doesn't
move but he will like shoot and do stuff
like that and then at any point I can
hit the button again and I swap with him
so I feel like that's gonna be really
useful during boss fights the other one
is I summon this little drone here and
then I can mark it and then the drone
will like attack enemies and do things
for me and both of those have like trees
you could suspect out so they'll be able
to do different things and have
different abilities
so anyway relax
it's Lorelei taken back watershed base
with a little help
I've got hang about
this is my seat mustache guess I'm a
vault hunter no matter crimson Raider
and a handsome bastard I'm a lot of
things you don't need all that I'm a
one-man our murder what city with a
single-digit army
they're good Reese really good and we
need all the help we can get
bandits are pouring into the city and
they're working with Palawan
looks like cutter girl was made a deal
with top agent is gearing up to strike a
battle on strategic you mind go meet up
with my agent Reese out while you go
mitrice's agent I'm gonna get this base
back online and start securing more of
the city Oh before you head off I've got
something for you yeah so as someone
pointing on the Chad they think Reese's
new voice actor is bad I'm not a fan
myself it's not that like his deliveries
bad it's that you have it's not the same
as voice actors Troy Baker combined with
the fact that the writers of Reese what
L tell not gearbox so I feel like you're
running into a situation where like
everyone who's writing this character is
not the original people involved with
him so he doesn't feel like the same
character like everything about his
dialogue in this vo it doesn't feel like
Reese and I find that kind of
disappointing I hope it I hope that it's
better later on I I don't know how big
of a role he has on the story if like
he's just here for this part on
Promethea but yeah I'm also kind of not
that into it personally it's a little
disappointing for me
since you're heading downtown I'm
hooking you up with a cyclone it's fast
and light perfect forgetting about the
city streets take it for a spin
I got a quest from here caffeine yeah
let's do this what say we start
civilizing this war-torn city again
let's start with the most precious
commodity of all coffee I'm feeling
right ragged and when a commander makes
mistakes people die and I'm sure my
troops could use a pick-me-up as well
head to the rise and grind coffee shop
to get started all right this is a
pretty good quest what are all the new
manufacturers so far I'm not sure as far
as hold on hit their arm button I need
to get the I want to get the new vehicle
going a cyclone is pretty cool
I would like ya the hyperion colors look
cool and that's about it
alright then I forgot you have to summon
it but yeah the good I had the assault
rifle that is a flat off weapon other
than that I haven't seen too many of the
new ones yet I'm sure there are but
everything I've found so far is all been
weapons that have existed manufacture
wise all right we're gonna get lower
layer copy
hello there
hold on I gotta kill you dude Jesus
hello yes
there we go anyway need a cup of our
cheery and super black power right into
a soup that'll get us up and running
power course it's always there damn
power cause all right where's that so
that was interesting that was a
conversation from the Calypso twins that
was like midway through and I think
because I was doing the side quest for
Lorelei it kind of like cut off the
beginning of their conversation and then
kept going hopefully that's something
they can they can fix cuz uh that'd be a
bummer I hate missing dialogue like that
poor daddy I just noticed that name I
never paid attention to that that's okay
I like that
whoa holy crap that's actually the first
time I've gone down there we go
just some iridium Karen we do anything
but right now but it is still a currency
I'm sorry
[Music]
hey level up
[Music]
and let's get you and we're good
oh never mind one more here we go
outside just toast the name of this
place is Ngoc station which is pretty
cool that's a nice little nod to general
Knoxx fair all right let's get a point
in oh I should have quipped that cryo
Nova is triggered that's cool there by
that cool that's useful unfortunately we
don't get like they have any seal points
so it's not like I get a really mess
with the full tree or anything it's
pretty limited but so far I like the
basic abilities for both characters
quite a bit
Nighy seconds you can just quickly hit Y
and respawn the vehicle right away you
don't have to worry about getting in the
menu every time so if you just need to
get your vehicle and go you can do that
all right give me my coffee
area can we get that coffee now barista
Oh
Wow bollocks wait wait I know there's a
malabon commando who's always got a
travel mug on him see if you can track
him down well this caffeinated sewer
juice my loved one cause coffee is
practically a war crime on its own I
just want that commanders mug
actually right right here please do
boots next time I'll do I'll do some
boots for you I'll boost it up
[Music]
a sniper
anything I'm a sniper still really loose
I feel like that needs a little bit of
adjusting it's compared to like
everything else like the second you zoom
in it's just it's like real swimmy
there's a couple snipers in particular
that are just like feels impossible to
aim with but again this is all by your
stuff I mean this game you know it's not
coming out till September that's all
polished that they can just work on I
feel like the core of the game right now
isn't really strong so Nate Craig
sup guys
[Music]
[Music]
there we go that's useful I got I got
stuck there for a minute so I choose my
clone to get out of that okay let's back
up a second
oh come on
I'm running and I like all the time I
don't know if I'm just not looting
enough or doesn't feel like enemies are
really dropping as much ammo maybe I
maybe I do need just a little more hello
no no take her time I don't have
anywhere else to be whatever man
you can't rush perfection
[Music]
come on come on what is taking so long
you're welcome have a lovely day oh
there we go out to my vehicle blow up
well now there is
[Music]
all right we're going to turn this in
and then we're gonna keep doing the main
story here we're gonna go meet Reese's
uh contact and get some more ammo good
lord
so it's free there just give me a moment
for you that's kind of nice
anything cool
you are my favorite person this was so
necessary godless boys rise and grinds
back in business and that copies are
made I go over there stoked
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
are you ready good not really
[Music]
what
thank you
oh it totally does yeah we just can't
show it off in this builds right now
yeah yeah the game totes multiplayer
it's your typical four player how is
this shotgun I need to find some better
guns I mean these are fine but I want
Chinese stuff out well we really can't
thank you I know this seems like a small
thing but even this little taste of the
world we lost it keeps us going you know
at least till tomorrow morning
all right cool let us continue on
[Music]
we want to go let's see here let's look
at the map yeah this that's pretty big
there's a lot to it so I think I go down
yeah let's go this way go down
[Music]
oh yeah guns on this thing aren't that
great so I'm just gonna keep moving here
we go let's find secrets yeah after I do
this
the main story stuff we got some time
hopefully I am down a hunt for some
secrets apparently there's some like
hidden chests and stuff around the area
you can try and find so I'd love to find
one of those boom boy
get back up
Sartain I using this slide as much I'm
not used to it in this game being an
option what's in general I mean I
typically don't slide in games because I
don't find them as well I'm curious of
all if I'll find it useful this one and
the game I slide the most and there's
something like titanfall or apex cuz you
just slide four days in those games try
kickback grenades kicking back a grenade
oh can you do that I will see if I can
do that
Oh corrosive weapons would be nice
it's anymore questions with the chat
please hit me up happy to answer
anything yeah give me a PM there we go
god I really like the way this looks I
was when they showed that first trailer
I was kind of under well my it felt like
it looked it looked a lot like Borland's
you know before look like Pandora this
stuff though is like really cool like I
think more more things like this and
that new trailer they should at the end
of a stream they just had showed all the
different environments and now I'm like
way more interested in seemed all that
stuff
there we go he didn't pay to play the
demo and how do I get your job oh I
haven't heard that before that's cool
though this whole thing for Tanis but
you have like am I getting paid for this
I mean I'm not getting paid by 2k or
gearbox I am getting paid by GameSpot to
be here in which case work work on your
video production
you boys zero i never played him in two
but i know a lot of people like him we
went to the same assassin bars i'm
really curious how many of the other
characters from the past games are gonna
show up so we saw zero maya we saw but
accident like accident I don't know if I
care about accident personally but I'm
sure someone would like to see accident
I would love to see like the Salvador
the gun Zurcher I'd love to see gage I
liked gage a lot I thought she was a
really fun character
Krieger riot yeah I know people like
Krieg as well like I hope everyone makes
at least a cameo in some form or another
I'm sure they can't all be integral to
the story but if they see the moment
that's enough for me hop down
I'll stop Fiona from pre-sequel we got
Reece but I mean fiona was so good like
I really I was really hoping she'd be
like a playable vault hunter because
that was like her whole character arc
where she was being trained to be one I
thought that'd have been so cool who
knows
neat ladder is DLC that'd be cool that's
just me spectating though are you there
you are
hell yeah I want three weapons if you
know is a lien vault hunter eval you're
like so majority of it but she like
becomes a better one that's like the
whole thing that's the whole her whole
character arc where I'm homeboy go down
there oh there is oh no that's my phone
when those weird oh you know what I
think he got a it didn't work because I
was like hitting up against the wall
back up here hey cakes cakes there we go
shield down
nope not gonna work
pack up and do some sniping the graphics
card on your PC using uh X you don't
know it's where I'm pretty sure it's a
Radeon because I think they're sponsored
by them for this event but that's all I
know I couldn't tell you the exact card
that's been there
there
[Music]
we saw this going oh hello there
yep purple purple purple what do we got
what do we got all right what's our next
thing okay then you got a fire that's
cool what do we got here yeah well this
was thing it's bed frame students
playing console I'm not playing any on
console I'm actually playing on PC it's
a combination of one I think the game
isn't fully optimized yet it is still an
early build also I think it's because
I'm streaming as well its straining on
the same PC I think that is slowing it
down when I played yesterday wasn't
streaming it and I found it was a lot
better I wasn't getting as much like lag
and stuff like that we salute
hi I'm inch I just kinda wanna know this
oh this one the Alice ones with the
tracker
it's like single fire though I'm not
really into that sniper again I'm just
gonna try these I'm probably gonna I
definitely like the way that feels
better than that other one let's see
cialis pistol oh there's missiles this
is
I like the way this one feels hold on I
want to keep this one just in case I end
up liking it I am going to drop probably
you I need to find a vending machine for
now I wanna mess with this one inventory
is full what do you talk about what's up
yeah
thank you a very nice woman just came by
and dropped off a ton of loot for me so
let's look at all this stuff then
alright okay I like the way this feels
that's cool hold on for a sec guys I
just have to start firing all these guns
off
some charges has radiation and corrosive
that's cool I don't have to charge
though I'm not a fan of the charge
there's so many of them oh my god about
this boy okay I have to mess with this
one for a little bit what's this boy
similar one why they get just more
damage I'll stick with this one I really
like don't hate you crank it that's
really cool all right
oh wait I have to the same yeah I have
to the same thing hold on and I want to
get rid of this one with this okay there
we go
I'm telling forget about that too many
choices what do you do they just give
you all these guns yeah I'll take it but
I'm not gonna keep it cuz I got better
[ __ ] D anyway here you go looks like a
bore Lance to DLC now it definitely
feels like better than that I mean I
think just like the changes to sorry I
wanted her up this
that's Kasich our head of Palawan
mergers and acquisitions that guy is a
douche and he's way obsessed with yeah
no I mean you know obviously you can get
the hands on the game and feel for
yourself I I don't think it feels like a
Borderlands DLC it feels like a full
substantial sequel with all the
additions and changes they've been
making so far all right we got a boss
fight of course I don't mind explaining
for anyone who doesn't he can help me
buddy look give plenty of corporate AOS
immediate resource of blackmail
okay so let's head over there and fight
this boss with our new guns
[Music]
[Music]
all right that's a driving improved it
feels a little bit better it still
doesn't feel maybe as good as I'd
particularly wanted to I don't know if I
was asking for too much though it's not
a driving game or anything but I do
think it feels a little bit better
all right last time
okay let's see I need all these few guns
but I got rid of my shock one
see I got corrosive and I got fired
there we go
the whole thing is just gun just you
don't reload it it's just like overheats
which is pretty cool
there we go
oh that's cool
all right
let's check out our loose range
Jaime no I like the way this gun feels
see we got a sniper okay and I see right
here we got a legendary the smart gun I
got this before this is really cool
so it is a t door gun you shoot it right
there and then when I throw it it'll
drop this little brain that will crawl
around and attack people so we're
definitely gonna use that later there we
go there's the brain thank you for that
point okay
well go turn in this quest hello there
[Music]
I think I went the wrong direction
that's okay stay a little detour
[Music]
here we go
[Music]
like that turning that feels a lot
better than the original hunter what why
do you smell like brains and fried
circuitry you know what I don't want to
know
cool Rhys let em know you got the job
done i turn subtitles on I don't know if
I can yeah I got it
my best is 21 meters
yeah just ass I don't think they have
subtitles in the build yet so sorry all
right cool
I like got the ability for class mods
don't think I have one though so this is
like technically the end of the build
but you can still explore around and do
any side quest you miss stuff like that
so we'll probably go to hers yep there
it is ooh there we go okay cool so let
me quickly sell my stuff because we want
to mess with that brain gun I know you
guys want to see that okay let's grab
this quest now that we've got coffee
priority number two is food malabon
recently took over the dynasty diner
which was pumping out food for our
people before it got taken go find the
owner bow and help him take his diner
back
all right let's do it here we go
and on a personal note there's this my
loved one guy captain Roy who's been
giving me no end of trouble I haven't
been able to pin him down but I hear
he's got a serious I need help damn it
did Lorelei send you oh it's me and I've
got hungry people back at the base I'd
get you Lorelei I so get you okaythen
let's try this gun out so that's a
classic West he wants you to build him a
basically a girlfriend so he wants you
to like collect other claptraps there he
goes come on
they're so creepy Oh God
box do you want speed man everyone wants
me to do stuff like the way this one
feels
there we go you're telling me really
stoked otters burgers Oh brain boy just
hanging out okay
oh all right
oh boy all right get my brain gun out
kill my brain army oh that's the one
here we go another hard lit now you
gotta fight some creatures - those are
always like the nasties party
Borderlands all the weird creatures they
come up with
oh all right guys so I'm not sure how
much longer we have probably wrapping
winding down fairly soon so if you guys
have any more questions about the game
as I'm playing here that you want to
know please let me know on the chat
there's gonna wrap up this burger quest
hopefully
negative priority one directive deliver
burgers tamela one Captain Archer row
all right oh I'm missing all these signs
I want to get come back later
well the melons attack those only wants
the burger
how does a man feel he's pretty good I
originally tried a Myra and I just I
liked playing sirens that's kind of like
my go-to character but I like his
abilities his like clone is really cool
his little like sentry bot school I like
that you can have two of them at the
same time if you want and replace of a
grenade like I seem like they kind of
knew that like you know maybe the
soldier type classic he's kind of
filling is a little generic and I think
they wanted to try and make it like more
appealing and I think they did a pretty
good job I really like him I don't know
who I'm gonna play though I really want
to see what the other two characters how
they function before I kind of decide
but I might end up going siren because
that's just kind of my thing
[Applause]
[Music]
better than pre-sequel I like to feel
better than pre-sequel so far I mean
science equals fine as a game but it's
not the best I think it's I didn't I
didn't like the oxygen mechanic that
much and then I thought the
environmental design wasn't as good I
like the way this feels so far I like
the environmental design the emphasis on
like thinking about the mantle seems
like it could potentially add a lot
thanks sorry got intense
there are some brain boys out
yes by a stream rage too before relief
oh whoa whoa stream that whenever we get
that game I'm sure I'm gonna roll odd to
Borderlands 2 is better than free single
do you agree yeah yeah boy let's do this
rather than the pre-sequel but I would
definitely agree with that
[Music]
oh hello
Oh
only three this gun feels a lot
oh [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah all
right there we go I move a lot faster in
the second wind when you're down like
you can actually move at a decent
location Jim as it'll make it easier to
get Oh
[Music]
[Music]
I want rats getting out of this seems
cool here--all just messing around some
guns but remain time we have left
what's your opinion on the weapon
abilities I like them a lot are the
alternate fire stuff is really really
cool I think there's a lot of like
really cool potential for combos like
having like a grenade launcher attached
here
assault rifles really need the like
robot brain thing is really funny and
actually super useful brain is best
waifu absolutely taking out captain row
volt hunter burger grubby prick has been
a right thorn in my ass but now he's
dead well done indeed first coffee now
burgers the cornerstones of civilization
piece by piece we're really starting to
put this city back together thanks for
your help
cool alright and see you got a rocket
launcher what if I can mess with that
real quick
alright looks like it's fairly standard
rocket launcher I never really liked
some rocket launcher eats and the other
games never used it myself
I can't wait to series so we actually
saw recently or you can check out
earlier in the stream if you want to see
that so ok we have done let's just
explore somewhere
see if we can find some stuff
[Music]
there's a area over here
[Music]
all right see what's down here rocket
launchers are good for second wins ask
you
okay cool I came across like a little
bounty to do through zero that's neat if
the games got a lot of stuff like this
we just kind of come across little
events like that that's really neat I
like that poured some water on it
holy crap that's getting hectic
[Music]
in my brain
or iridium
there we go
oh my god they're just gonna keep coming
maybe alright let's move on
[Music]
I really like this vehicle a lot alright
let's go straight to the rear
[Music]
else we got okay
[Music]
[Music]
you can feel more fluid like 60fps uh
it's not it's definitely not 60fps but
this is an early build so obviously like
it's not fully optimized yet but I mean
I'm playing on the PC here with the
controller and I think it feels pretty
good when the frame rates up there I
imagine you know when the game comes out
it'll it'll be fine oh my brain boys
who think st. is taking a bit of zeros
powers yet they can't talked about that
in the preview where it's like he's got
zeros power with with the clone and then
he's got like but his shield is a little
bit of like Roland's power where it kind
of has a similar function to the turret
it doesn't shoot though but it can like
heal you and stuff like that and then
his turret is kind of a little more
involved but yeah it's like he's kind of
a mix of like those three characters
rolled up into one which makes them
really interesting hello there
jeez I'm run out of ammo doing anything
is so weird
although I'm going to switch my weapons
over I want you and I want you and I
want you okay
let's preach that sorry when you do that
to them however I do not like that you
have to charge the gun like this like
you can't just like pull the trigger you
have to hold it up and it takes so long
to do and the damage isn't as much as
you want it to be where I don't know if
I love this kind of gun alright is that
in this area well let's take this little
area I might not be able to get in here
and this demo okay we move on I imagine
a lot of these areas they'll have more
dust in them I'm just gonna run pass
these guys I mention these areas have a
lot more in them in the full game
okay switch coaches in the demo
unfortunately I cannot okay so that's
the journals of the first of all talk to
that Tennyson wanted me to get uh yeah
it does you can't switch characters
unfortunately the demo I see someone's
asking me if it feels slow defend to the
other games it actually feels faster
everything about it feels faster paced
not quite as slow which i think is good
i mean stuff like the alternate weapons
and they like the slide like i think the
game just has an overall faster feel
then pass borderlands games anything
else it's kind of it
my piece and like little mix and
crannies I miss
[Music]
I do like that as you explore the map
actually fills in to kinda let you know
like where you've already been I find
that very useful that was always
something with the other borderland so I
was like have I been here yet I mean
like fully explored this area what's
never really sure oh I got a little
quest over here I can try and start it I
probably won't get to finish it in time
but we can start it up I really need
more ammo though good lord
some fancy nerd tech but we haven't
heard from him in a while I'll make sure
he's not dead right
and either way try to get me the digits
truck plans for this north hacking thing
he's been working on it really help us
out we can turn those billboards to our
side
you do let's see there's my vehicle
yeah where do I have to go one down
there okay
[Music]
oh okay just go back out it's a bit like
titanfall so actually it's funny enough
apparently they were kind of influenced
a little bit by the speed of titanfall
but I think like stuff like the sliding
and then there's like that one character
whose ability it's just straight up like
a mech that unfortunately can't mess
with but that sounds the crazy so I'm
kind of like I'm curious to see how much
like titanfall influences in this game
because it seems like they definitely
pay attention to it all the frame rate
in this area is way better mo oh thank
god
and get them let's try Alton I want
radiation
I guess I have to look around
[Music]
have the infinity pistols back not sure
okay maybe nope
I'll just keep polluting stuff I haven't
spent steal points thank you I should
actually do that it's like weird I'm
like nothing kind of do it cuz I'm just
like it's like whatever I'm already here
fractal frags let's copy if this current
frag drops a free grenade
[Music]
okay hmm weird I can't find the next
part to this quest well maybe I should
just move on for the purposes of
continuing to show you guys stuff
it's like glowing star on you on your
screen I believe that is my shield
[Music]
and this planet looks really cool I
really like it a lot I go what's over
here let us explore I didn't have this
chest yet that they were talking about
that's hidden in here maybe over here
all right we're going off the rails
what's over here
[Music]
vehicle combat ie able to switch guns on
those vehicles yes there's customization
for the guns on the vehicles we don't
have the option to customize right now
but you totally can
oh it just brings me back over here okay
oh and everyone's gone alright yeah yeah
let's quest here right so as you can see
life sucks right there's these two
melawan guys
Max and Max who are crapping it up in
particular it's like they're trying to
out war crime each other one of them box
it back yes she is I don't know who did
it
[Music]
[Music]
killed who I'm gonna get my revenge
it's a pretty good quest I like this one
it's got some good it's a very
classically
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
play co-op with a friend unfortunately
can on this build
I hope the game has more this kind of
stuff like that was something they were
doing a lot too and pre sequel like
having alternate variations of quests
and stuff like that you know you get
side objectives or sometimes get like
alternate like I you could like turn in
quest to different people and you get
like different rewards I hope they keep
expanding upon that stuff I really liked
that with those quest lines I don't
think they're gonna go full like
meaningful choices or anything like that
I don't expect them to do that but
variations that lead to alternate
dialogue or rewards a good time what do
you have to use the controller for the
PC demo it's because the PC controls are
probably not optimized yet I've had this
happen before where I tried using mouse
and keyboard and it like fell off and
they were like oh yeah it's because we
have in like next we'd like the
sensitivity and like you know like that
kind of stuff yet so it it's just safer
to use the controller is what they'd
prefer oh thank you thank you very much
all right we got blessed with more guns
so let's take another opportunity here
to look at all these oh my god better
shotgun there
Hey
I like the feeling of this gun it's a
good submachine gun see sniper
yes this is pretty good got that like
barrel these are some my favorite guns
of Borderlands 2 or the kind that had
like the rotating barrel on the sniper
let's see what else do we got uh we got
this on top of each other I can't even
see them all about this one I know
that's the one that turns the legs
actually no there's no grade okay that's
cool whoo like the way this looks I
won't try it out oh cool this is an
ALICE gun that is a dual carbine
okay this is maybe my favorite gun I've
found so far this is absolutely my jam
suppose these guys want me to shoot them
which is really funny
yeah
I like the way this gun feels a lot this
is a really good gun doesn't have any
fancy abilities just good and a uniques
with red textile yeah we take a look at
some of the tech stuff if you want uh
actually no there doesn't seem to be any
flavor text no it's possible they
haven't wrote it in yet but it doesn't
seem to be any flavor text or anything
okay apparently got seven minutes left
one of these any other guns here I
missed I don't we're trying out I'm
gonna miss more with this gun that way
yet alright we'll finish up this quest
here
I wish some hoots punlewd for me I know
right you're just playing a game so long
spine spawns wait for you
[Music]
I loot drop share so they were saying
that during the presentation that you
can have instant flute where it will no
longer be everyone will see their own
separate loot and that way no one has to
worry about someone taking someone
else's loo or worried stuff like that
however if you don't want to play the
game that way and you prefer to play it
the way Borderlands like 1 & 2 works
where it is all shared loo and and you
kinda have to fight over it and stuff
like that you could totally turn that on
so I think it's gonna be kind of like
how you and your friends prefer to play
it all right no second-guessing does
that mean if a legend area drops
everyone gets a copy I don't know I I
don't know if it's always the same gun
set drop or if there are different guns
that drop or if those guns are tweaked
like a Borderlands 2 when you get a gun
for beating a quest here everyone would
get the same base gun but then they get
different variations on it so it's like
Oh mines like a real a slag version of
this weapon or mine's got like a scope
or something like that so it's possible
that say everyone gets the maybe
everyone will get a legendary but that
legendary will have different properties
to it so everyone might get a different
version of that legendary can't really
say though since we have another chance
to actually like try co-op in and see
the differences don't really know
[Music]
do you think that duping will still be
in the game I'm sure you know people
always find a way to do stuff like Adam
duping and you know people will figure
that stuff out I'm sure I'm sure people
will figure out ways to do things like
that I gotta go back to kill this other
guy
thanks for being real of course what's
the consensus so far it's good I like it
it feels good I was definitely feeling
more positive on it than I was initially
I think that reveal trailer just didn't
do that much for me but having like a
chance to actually like sit down and
play it I really like the way it feels
I like the improvements and changes to
the guns I really like the new
environment so far it all feels pretty
good I like some of the characters stuff
so far I like war a lie a lot I don't
know how I feel about the new villains
they're kind of they're supposed to be
like annoying YouTube stir like twitch
streamers which I get and maybe works a
little too well right I don't like
listening to them but we'll see
hopefully hopefully I can like
appreciate them without liking them
which i think is what they're trying to
go for but alright we'll turn in this
quest and then I think that'll be it
we'll have exhausted pretty much
everything it moves demo at this point
other than finding those those rare
chests which is a bummer I never found
one
[Music]
[Music]
see those jumping jacks how's the talent
tree looks good so far we're gonna have
a breakdown of that over on gamespot.com
if you want to check that out but it's
like it's hard to get a sense for right
now like what's like the best ability
cuz I actually can't like use a lot of
them cuz it's not like I have like a ton
of skills or anything like that so here
I go to the skill tree I kind of look at
them like there's definitely a lot of
cool abilities like you can like use I
can like use my digi clone and like to
stray it to immediately get like a
second wind with full health like stuff
like that
Jeffster ignore bullets whenever you
freeze enemy get some of them damage
back as health like there's a lot of
things in here that seem really really
cool it's just that I don't have the
skill points to mess with them so it's
hard to say like how useful these
actually are but they seem exciting
alright guys well I think that's about
it I'll probably just call it here thank
you so much for watching this has been
an interesting event you normally we
don't get to do this where we actually
like go to a pre event like this
actually get you stream the game usually
they don't want to do that but they feel
pretty confident the game and I can see
why I think it's pretty good so far
obviously we'll see more about it in the
coming months if you guys liked this and
you want to see more gameplay we do have
gameplay of the other character my amira
of the siren you can go check that out I
put up like all of my demo of that that
you can go watch it's like an hour long
and it doesn't have anyone talking so if
you just want to watch like pure
gameplay without someone else in a pip
you should go check that out and yeah
thanks for watching guys and we will
catch you next time